Hey Mark, check it out.
I made a directed graph of all
the tasks I need to do to become
a gentleman's spy.
>> Okay, let's see.
Being smooth depends on
an intimate knowledge of whiskeys?
>> Hm.
>> Which depends on spending a year at a
mountain monastery devoting your life to
meditation and whiskey sampling?
>> Yeah.
See,
I even configured each
task with the group.
One for marksmanship, one for
counterintelligence, one for
looking good in a suit.
>> Sure, but do you actually
know how to do all these tasks?
Like, for example what would
be in the action list of
the shockingly good at fencing task?
>> Good point.
Well, other people have become
gentleman spies in the past.
I'll just look up a documentary on
James Bond, or Sterling Archer and
I'll figure it out.
>> You realize these
are fictional characters, right?
>> That's just your opinion, man.
Rumor has it,
they were actually based on-
>> Never mind.
>> But you do have a good point.
We've learned a lot about the nuts and
bolts of how to declare, configure, and
run Gradle tasks.
But we still don't know how to define
the tasks you'd need to build,
say, a Java project.
Hey, super spy!
[SOUND].
What would be the console commands you'd
use to compile and build a Java project?
>> It'd be like, Java C something,
and then you'd need to add some stuff
[CROSS-TALK]
>> Oh.
>> Mm-hm, writing your tasks to build
a Java project would be a huge pain.
Especially if we wanted to
make sure it was all portable.
Thankfully, my colleagues at Gradle,
as well as hundreds of
community contributors.
Have developed a huge number of plugins
that define useful tasks for you.
We don't have to write a single
task to build a Java project.
We just need to import
the task from the Java plugin.
Too bad we can't import any spy skills.
>> It's all right.
I really wanted to be
a build engineer anyway.